So, are you still a Christian? I still believe in God,
but I don't think that I did. You were a guy that wouldn't trick off.
I not until I was like 17. Yeah. Yeah. When I met you, you're like, Nope,
wait, hang on. I want to get, I wanna get into this. Um,
so what would you do when you would feel the urge?
Were you allowed to use your rub up against a wall without using your hands?
Jesus, no, I would get super creative.
I would go to a rock climbing gyms, just, you know,
just get stuck [inaudible] for a little bit.
Uh, well, I, I don't know. So until older,
like I literally just didn't know I had no sex education at the
Christian school that I went to. They literally like,
we ain't going to skip this section. Oh, wow. Yup.
Yup. We're going to move on from that. Yeah.
And it was one of those things where I was like, okay,
I just started getting an ungodly amount of where I was just like, this is,
this is crazy. Yeah. Like I was like, dude,
if I hugged a girl in the hallway at high school,
it was like immediately.
And I'm wearing like basketball shorts and I'm the kid who's like walking,
like with the books and stuff, you know,
just trying to hide it and stuff like that.
So then I started jerking off and then, you know, loved it. And
if it feels so good, it feels real. And that looked like this. Oh God.
Was there a bagel on top? It was literally, yeah. There was a bagel there.
Um, did you ever go into pornography or no, I did. Um,
only a few scenes I shot. Um, but I, I would look at porn,
but there's a lot of guilt associated with that. And I actually,
so I haven't been looking at porn during the pandemic really,
which I've been trying to avoid doing it.
Cause I feel better about my relationship and everything with my wife when I'm
not looking at that stuff. I try not to consume that stuff because it makes,
it does make our sex better. For sure. Yeah. If I,
if I'm avoiding looking at like graphic stuff online, like it's just, it,
it is more special as cheesy as that sounds. But, uh, I do think like I've,
I've done it both ways, but when I'm, when I was on the road, it's like,
you gotta take care of it on the road. And I would like, you know, go to town,
like you'd have to yeah, you have to. Yeah.
Do you get girls hitting on you on the road now or no,
I don't think I put out that vibe. You don't have a sexual,
I know you're a sexual being. Right, right, right. No,
I'm going to throw that out there. Yeah.
You're a very sexual being and I could see why women would be attracted to you.
Thank you so much. Bye. But um, you have
[inaudible] [inaudible] yeah. Yeah. It's like a mute, Dante, you know,
you have a very, like what, what is that disease that, where, um,
the skin is inside out Harlequin.
Bobby would send me photos all the time and say, I just found your doppelganger.
You would send me those photos all the time.
All the time you send me like graphic stuff.
One time we were looking at, we were watching one of those shows and I,
the kid had like Pierre, Robin syndrome. And you were like, this is a baby.
Yeah. But you know, um, I apologize again. Um, it's okay.
I'm changing as a person. I have to apologize.
Cause one time I did something as a comic that was very embarrassing in front of
you Khalilah this and you, I doubt you. I doubt you remember this.
I remember everything you remember. Everything we were at,
we are at a yard house after one of the shows at the improv and we were eating
and Bobby was making Asian jokes and he was like saying jungle
Asian and all this stuff. And I think I said like an Asian.